and finally new rule no more swiping
left on perfectly good presidential
candidates nearly 45 million Americans
now identify themselves as Democrats and
all of them are running for president
this time let's give them a chance let's
not eat our own the way we nitpicked
Hillary to death over her emails and
other [ __ ] Kamala Harris has already
had to play defense because it's come
out that when she was a prosecutor she
prosecuted people not very progressive
she should have found a way to apply
more forgiveness and the fact that she
didn't it's unforgivable Elizabeth
Warren claimed to be Native American so
what Trump claimed to be human
[Music]
if you think this stupid blown out of
proportion
Indian controversy makes her inauthentic
you're the phony she is Li champion of
consumer rights in the age of income
inequality when it comes to Elizabeth
Warren I have no reservations
okay Bernie Sanders we used to like him
but he didn't personally chaperone
everyone on his campaign so he's a sex
monster once removed the candidate has
to have tough standards for their staff
but not too tough
that's Amy Klobuchar oh yeah yeah last
week we learned she's verbally abusive
then again this came from The Huffington
Post so I gotta ask do you mean actually
abusive or what Millennials think of as
abusive because because I think it's
like the pain chart in the hospital and
I think my generations too is your
generations 10
so
so welcome to the real world snowflake
now go get Amy her coffee and shut the
[ __ ] up
[Applause]
better O'Rourke took oil money yeah he's
in Texas all the money in Texas is oil
money
the only other job there is operating
the mechanical bull
it's like complaining Mitt Romney takes
money from Mormons I mean jeez every
Democrat is going to have some dark spot
in Virginia it's on their face
do you know what song Trump plays at his
rallies it's the stones you can't always
get what you want which seems like an
odd choice but it tells you why
Republicans are so successful because
they're not babies who think they can
have everything Evangelic uns don't
really like Donald Trump they know he
can't even pass the church without
bursting into flames but but he got them
two justices on the Supreme Court
yeah you can't always get what you want
but if you try sometimes you get what
you need that's their jam
ours is thank you next we go from I love
you to die in about six hours it's like
dating Taylor Swift you know I've been
watching the reboot of temptation Island
not to brag and it's startling how
similar the mentality is to what's going
on in the Democratic Party if you're not
familiar temptation Island is the show
where hot people dating hot people are
in search for hotter people contestants
only have two emotions horny and crying
and the whole point of the show is you
can always do better every contestant
begins their journey by saying the same
thing I love what I have with Trevon but
I wonder if there's someone more perfect
for me there isn't that new [ __ ] in
the tank top is the same as your [ __ ]
in the tank top this this is a real
problem in our society looking for an
excuse to dump someone someone good
because there must be one more perfect
and sometimes what you wind up with is
no one to host the Oscars at all yeah
yeah look at the Oscars they're being
ruined by these same kind of ridiculous
purity tests Bohemian Rhapsody is flawed
flawed because it's gay but not gay
enough really that's what they're saying
it's insensitive to the extremely gay
what four years to do for years the beef
about gay characters in movies was they
were reduced to their sexuality now the
sexuality is placed in the background
and it wears the dick-sucking
roma Roma delivers such an authentic
portrait of a Mexican housekeeper Arnold
Schwarzenegger tried to impregnate but
it's a movie about the poor and the
director isn't poor out green book is a
movie made by liberals for liberals
bursting at the seams with liberal
values not good enough because the
director is one of the farily brothers
and as an inside joke for his crew he
used to pull his weenie out on movies
like Dumb and Dumber [ __ ] the poster for
Something About Mary showed Cameron Diaz
his hair styled with Ben Stiller's come
I say you should get an award just for
growing up and then there's a star is
boring which has big problems with
consent
yes consent because get this Bradley
Cooper pulls Lady Gaga on stage to sing
without her knowledge thereby forcing
her to endure the humiliation of global
stardom
I'm not kidding the review and box says
a star is born presents a codependent
relationship built on a huge power
imbalance and lack of female agency
that's what you got out of a star is
born because all I learned was don't
wear khakis on stage when you really
have to pee
you